Hey YouTube it's Charlie! So Game of Thrones
season six has already started casting some
characters, and a lot of people think that Euron
Greyjoy might be one of them. So I'm gonna read
this casting description and then explain
him a little bit. So, the casting description
reads: "A male pirate in his 40s to late 50s
who is terrorizing the seas all around the
world. Cunning, ruthless with a touch of madness.
He's a dangerous looking man". So, right away
this screams Euron Greyjoy, one of Theon's uncles. He's a really big character in the
books but he hasn't really shown up 'till books
four and five so far. That's why we haven't seen
them on the show. There is another uncle called
Victarion who kinda gets tied up with Euron
story. Until now it just seemed like the show
is gonna completely cut out the rest of
the Ironborn storyline, which everyone got
really upset about, because: they're really big
group in the books, that play a really big
part in the war of ice and fire. It's just that any
time the show cuts characters out, like young
Griff, it just, it makes people feel like they're
dead ends in the books. That isn't the case, I mean, you know, young Griff plays a really big
part in the books: is just the show tries to
be a little more economic in the scope of
the narrative. That's what happens when you
only get 10 episodes of season. It's not confirmed
that Euron is the character that they're casting, it's
still a fan theory. You know, but based on that
description and the way that they cast characters
for the show that is the best theory so far.
Usually what happens is: is when they first
start casting characters like, you know, right
around this time of the year, they cast the
really big ones first, the ones that they announce
at Comic Con every year. And then they-they pick
up some of the lesser ones along the way.
The latest I remember them casting someone in
season four was the child of the forest that
we saw on the season four finale: they didn't
announce that 'till, like, November 2013 I think.
So even though they start shooting really
early, they still cast people throughout the
years they need them in episodes. Is just,
you know, the bigger characters they needed in
more episodes they had to cast them sooner. So
regardless of who this, like really big people
that they're just starting to cast right now
are, will probably get to meet them at Comic Con.
Last year they announced the Sand Snakes, Doran
Martell, Areo and the High Sparrow. It's really like the
only new material that the show ever brings
to Comic Con. The-they don't bring trailers
for the new season. In all fairness to the
producers though: the reason they don't print
footage is because they haven't started shooting
the new season yet so there's nothing to show.
But just to do a quick rundown of Euron in
the books: he's Theon's oldest uncle. Theon's
father Balon Greyjoy's oldest brother. He's described
as being handsome, but he's only got one eye
and he drinks this-this is blue drink every night
that give his lips this constant bluish cast,
He claims to have- one time had a dragon
egg, that he said he threw overboard in one
of his "moods". It sounds like he got really
frustrated and drunk one night and just decided
to check it overboard because he couldn't
figure out how to hatch it. He claims to have
sailed all the way to Asshai, which is actually
were Melisandre's from, it's-it's on the other
side of the Eastern Continent, so it's actually
really really far away. He even claims to have
walked through the ruins of ancient Valyria
that-that's the place where Tyrion and Jorah
went a couple episodes ago. In the timeline,
you know, right around with season one is picking
up, he's been banished from the iron islands
for raping his brother Victarion salt wife.
If that doesn't seem bad enough, you know, salt-
salt wives, you have to remember, are women that
the Ironborn captured during raids and turned in to
bound concubines. So, all you already were
on like shaky ground here: he raped his brothers
concubine who his brother himself had captured
and then been raping. But is not that all sounds:
they still have a code they live by. They're
not allowed to kill kin so his recompense: Euron
was banished. So in the time that the show
is been going on, like, as-as the stories been
moving along, he's just been out ceiling around.
Maybe he knows where Gendry is, who knows. Victarion, in the in the context of the story,
is the commander of the Iron fleet, he stays
pretty close to the Seastone chair. So he commands
Balon Greyjoy's forces in the War of the
Five Kings. The show, thus far, has given most
of that storyline to Theon's sister, so it's possible
that the shows going with Euron tho just completely
cut out Victarion. They'll give, like, all of
the Victarion story to Euron. The reason everyone
thinks it's going to be Euron and not Victarion is because George RR Martin describes
Victarion as a dullard and a brute. And dullard
just doesn't scream cunning as is described in
this pirate casting call. He's still pretty interesting
character like he wears full plate mail and
he associates with the priest of the Red
God, who's a character that the show might do.
So I'm gonna save him for later just-just
in case they do cast the character. The cool
thing about the Ironborn is-is that it also
kind of brings in some more context for the
priests of the Red God. So, you know, hopefully
in season six we will get to see the inside
of a red temple, or at least get to learn more about
the faith of the Red God. Most of the show
this far has been spent in Westeros; the dominant
religion there is the Faith of the Seven. Melisandre
and Thoros of Myr were actually sent to Westeros
to-to try get like a foothold for the
faith of the Red God: to try spread
the religion. That's why Melisandre was so
disappointed in Thoros whenever she met him.
He'd been sent to Kings Landing and utterly
failed in his mission. In addition to Euron
and Victarion, tho, Balon actually has two
other brothers: we might see one of the other
ones. Just going in order: Euron is the oldest,
then there's Victarion, then Euron-gone (?)
who actually died as a child so we're-we're
never gonna see him. Then there's Aeron: the Damphair. There is a scene in season two where Theon
gets baptized by someone that looks like Aeron, but he wasn't called Aeron in the script.
So he-he could be just some random character.
The reason you should be excited about Euron
Greyjoy though, is that because of-of all Theon's
family he is the most fun character. Most of
the personalities in Theon's family flow
from Balon Greyjoy. There are a lot of variations,
they are all very different characters. Euron himself
has said to have always followed the old ways:
they judge you based on your ability as a
raider. Like the-the only jewelry they wear
around are ornaments that they win in battle
or spoils of war like trophies that they were
around. I think one of the reasons why people
like the Ironborn so much is just-is just
because they are so open about their lifestyle.
Their default mode is to take what they want:
like rating and being pirates are historically
their main industry. That changes a little
in recent years but they still Reaven rate,
you know, taking whatever they want, but, not nearly
as much as they used to. Balon Greyjoy was
suppressed after the Greyjoy rebellion that
that's like in the events leading up to season
one. So they were much quieter in recent years.
Obviously the war the five kings change
that, though: Balon Greyjoy declares himself
King of the Iron Islands and, you know, they start making war on the East Coast. The circumstances of
Euron's return are, you know, his arrival in
the story and person are kinda spoilery so I'm
not to talk about those now. If you do and
if you have read the books please use spoiler
tags. On the show he's supposed to be in his
40s or 50s; in the books Euron is only in his
30s. But you remember that everyone the shows
is kinda aged up about 10 years. But Jamie and Cersei
are about 10 years older they-they're in their
40s instead of the 30s. Tommen is probably
the best example of that: in the books he's only
about nine years old. Obviously they're not
going to make Natalie Dormer have sex with a little
kid, so you get the idea. Most of the Ironborn
we've see on the show so are-are fairly practical
people, you know, like they have their own religion,
they worship the drowned God, we've seen bits
of that. Euron though, you know, as is described,
has a touch of madness: so his ambitions are
much much grander. And we're kind at that time
in the in the story whereby things are reaching
a crescendo so you expect crazier and crazier
characters to come on. That's one of the challenges
the show: as-as we approach like the final
season is that the spectacles had to get bigger
and bigger and bigger. Euron is a character
that fits really well with that metaphor. Like I said they, you know, they may casting announcements
for 11 other characters, so there's a lot of
other people that we can talk about about
I'll probably wait 'till after the season to do them. There's still a lot of things left that can happen
so, you know, after the finale it'll be a little
bit easier to make predictions about which
characters they're bringing on. Here's my big question for you guys though: do you think that the show
is bring on Euron Greyjoy? And if they do: do
you think that they just, you know, combine a couple
other Ironborn characters and give that story
to him? As much as the show cuts out they still
try to do relatively big storylines. You know, sometimes
thay have to swap characters based on people that
they killed off or people that they cut on
entirely. Speaking of which: George RR Martin
actually just announced that he's not going
to be writing any scripts for season six. Some
people are freaked out by this, but I actually
think it's a good thing because he said it
would take a month away from writing Winds of Winter. He just said that it takes him about
three weeks to write a script and then, like,
a week after that to get back into book mode.
So, you know, what would you rather have, like: a George RR Martin episode or Winds of Winter? The best
theory right now is that, you know, based on the
pace of his writing, he'll finish somewhere
around the beginning of season six, you know, or at least by the end of season six. So as much as the show
is passing the books in the timeline, they-
they will kinda even up, you know, 'round season
six. It's not gonna be perfect, but, if you're a book
purist, you will have that material to read.
door, when that actually, when that does drop,
I will give away a bunch of copies. The people
that actually won books this year, that won the signed copies that I-that I sent out, should
be receiving them pretty soon. The other really
cool thing about that, thus: later this year
George RR Martin is re-releasing the Dunk and
Egg stories, like, he's just combining them
all in a single book called: "A Knight of the
Seven Kingdoms". That's coming in October so
I'll giveaway copies whenever that happens. Until
then, like the weekly giveaways, like right
now, will still be the HBO Now subscription.
But I'll probably do an extra special giveaway
for the finale. My episode eight video tonight
will post right after the episode here so,
be sure to Subscribe to get that. That-that's
when the new round of the giveaway will start.
If there are any bonus videos that you guys
really want for next week, just be sure to
leave me request in the comments. So while you wait for that to post you can click here for
last week's episode and you can click here
to learn all about Maester Aemon. Thank you
so much for watching, everybody: let's High
Five and I'll see you guys tonight!